everybody it's Charlie we got to talk
all about infinity war Inhumans
crossover and a bunch of you requested I
do shield stuff so I added that to the
end of this Marvel stuff blowing up all
over this year so there's a whole bunch
of stuff to explain but if you're new to
the channel I do Marvel videos for the
movies for the TV shows for the comics
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I do giveaways every week to that I'll
explain at the end of the video but the
big things going on here we'll start
with Inhumans Avengers infinity war a
crossover stuff then I'll talk about
agents of shields a big WTF with the
cliffhanger they're basically ending
this block of episodes the LMD block and
they're going to move into something
else but there was a big twist and you
guys are requesting a video so I'll
explain that after I do infinity war
inhuman so the big deal within humans is
that Ramsay Bolton from Game of Thrones
was just cast as Maximus the met the
brother of Black Bolt sort of the Loki
of that family you have to remember that
the Inhumans is kind of like this weird
offshoot group the x-men were always the
most popular characters in the comics
the Inhumans this is actually really
funny started during Fantastic Four I've
done a couple Inhumans videos in the
past like what agents of shield started
pushing into that storyline but the deal
with the TV show is that it's not being
designed is an agents of shield spin-off
it's completely separate it's an eight
episode miniseries it might get like 13
episodes in season two if it does really
well which it sounds like it will and
it's getting ready to film in Hawaii I
did a video about Namor a little while
ago because there's like a mystery
Marvel project that's filming down there
but they've just started casting the
series so we don't know who Black Bolt
is but we know who Maximus is they
confirm they're doing the entire royal
family and if you look at the age of
Ramsay Bolton here you can guess at the
age of the rest of the characters the
showrunner is the same guy that did iron
fist so this is all Marvel television
it's not Marvel's film division but
they're going to be rolling out a whole
bunch more information about the cast
that'll be like the next big thing that
everybody learns who are playing all
these characters who's going to be Black
Bolt who's going to be Medusa who's
going to be Karnak I'm actually really
excited about Karnak but obviously Black
Bolt is the big deal but the big problem
that Marvel has is in how it explains
their origin story and how they're only
now just making themselves known so in
the Marvel Universe they've been around
this whole time
in at LANs their city has just been
cloaked from view it's changed its
location a couple of times like it
started out on the far side of the Moon
then it went below the ocean then it
went above New York City after the
infinity arc so there's a lot of
problems that they can solve by just
streamlining their origin story in tying
it with infinity war now the movies
usually don't crossover with the TV
shows the TV shows are free to borrow
whatever they want though it is a very
connected universe but it's kind of a
one-sided connectedness so even though
this inhuman show is like a really big
deal I'm not expecting to see any of
them in infinity war they haven't even
shot it yet so Kevin Feige behind the
scenes probably has a few ideas about
how he'll connect things so what they
might end up doing because the show is
going to drop before infinity war drops
infinity war the movie is 2018 this show
is going to premiere this September it's
going to be badass is that they
piggyback on the Civil War sokovia
accords that slowly brings them into the
limelight and then in the second season
they can address the blowback of
infinity war which actually was a big
thing in the comics if you remember the
Terrigen bomb from infinity they try to
do a version of that on agents of shield
with the fish oil pills I wasn't a big
fan with the twist but they were trying
to do their own version of that where
they just create a whole bunch of
Inhumans all at the same time so this
show is going to start out relatively
self-contained but it exists in the MCU
so what they might do is just piggyback
on some of the comic book infinity
twists whereby Thanos does some really
big damage issues big threats to the
earth give me the infinity gems or else
so we have the plot of infinity war [ __ ]
gets crazy what happened in the comics
is Thanos threatened to destroy a salon
unless Black Bolt gave him tribute by
killing all Inhumans between ages 16 and
22 Santos was actually looking for his
son at the time now they're probably not
going to do him in the movies so don't
worry about some of the details but in
answer to his challenge Black Bolt set
off a Terrigen bomb
activating dormant in humans all over
the earth so you just have to have some
sort of impetus for Inhumans to be a big
deal in the world of the humans and what
they might do is they'll start off
relatively slow the way they did in Fant
take four like it was very secretive you
only knew about the couple of Inhumans
that were members of the royal family
but then you learned about their race
how they been hiding out this whole time
so that's probably what's going to
happen at tool and we'll be featured in
a series the way it was not featured on
agents of shield that was a huge bummer
and a lot of you are asking does that
mean that shield characters will get to
crossover with the Inhumans TV show in
as far as I know that is not the case
anything could change but the way they'd
explained it is that the Inhumans show
is not a spinoff it's designed to be its
own thing so they won't be forced to
deal with any of the twists or turns the
shield has set up so they don't have to
deal with fish oil pills or anything
like that and we don't even know which
time period it's going to be set in they
could actually choose to set this way in
the past so Black Bolt is actually about
the same age as Tony Stark and a lot of
the other main Avengers characters so
you have to imagine that if he showed up
in the movies he'd be a much older
character so since these are younger and
it's something of an origin story for
the black bull character and what we see
on the TV show during season one might
actually take place like 20 or 30 years
ago just depending on how old they want
to make him and modern continuity it
would probably be 80s or 90s because
they don't want to make him so old that
he's like an old man compared to Tony
Stark any other Avengers but I'm really
excited I'm totally happy with the
casting I think that he's perfect for
Maximus to Matt he plays crazy
characters so well if you don't remember
he actually played a pretty crazy
character on this British series called
misfits a whole bunch of juvenile
offenders get superpowers and it's sort
of like a Suicide Squad situation where
as they try to do good things and some
of them are good some of them are bad
but anyway it's going to be great we'll
do plenty of Inhumans videos this summer
if there any specific bonus videos you
want me to do for that just let me know
in the comments but like I said Avengers
infinity war fan o stuff will inform a
lot of what they do in future seasons
but because season 1 of the show is
coming first they don't have to deal
with it too much and it's not connected
to agents of shield so next big thing
agents of shield WTF so just careful for
spoilers from episode 15 of shield I'll
talk about a couple of a really big
twist and explain what's going on what
they're moving into and what's going to
be happening with season five because
the show has not been
dude yet in there a couple different
scenarios but I do think that they can
get more episodes I don't think they'll
cancel the show but here's the big deal
so at the end of the episode we learned
that they're all getting sucked into the
matrix Daisy has to help rescue them
with Simmons and a couple people's that
are left on the outside the superior is
now like the MODOK of the show he's like
the head in the jar controlling a life
model decoy version of himself in
Radcliff is dead the interesting thing
there were a lot of deaths in the
episode but Radcliffe is the only main
character that genuinely got killed off
so he's inside the matrix now his
consciousness still exists he's still a
character on the TV show but the big
twist is the stuff inside the matrix
that they tease agents of Hydra they
flashed this big logo and everyone's
like what does this mean what's going on
so the whole idea is that the matrix is
supposed to be this version of reality
that rolls back everyone's regrets so
the one regret and I think the big twist
here the Hydra twist is that Coulson
never joined shield that was his one
regret
so he's this professor here there's that
creepy music from the beginning of the
episode playing it seems like everyone
is enjoying themselves even May who is
in the Triskelion which hasn't been
destroyed has the big Hydra symbol on it
seems like she is satisfied with what's
going on it's meant to show how
important Coulson is to the Marvel
Universe he's the one that brought the
Avengers together that were able to
defeat Loki that helped inspire Captain
America to bring down Hydra during
Winter Soldier so like none of those
things ended up happening we learned the
superiors beef against Coulson was as
the eat felt like he was the one that
connected all of these crazy events
across all the movies all the past
seasons of the show you were here you're
the one common denominator with all
these things like there's a picture of
Thor's hammer there's iron man stuff
pretty much every time that Coulson is
popped up in the movies as well as the
big stuff on the TV show
meaning that Coulson is the most
important person in the Marvel Universe
according to this big twist hopefully
that explains the big Hydra twist but as
a consequence of that word is still
alive so we're going to continue to see
dead characters pop up in the final 7
episodes they did say
it was going to be like a love letter to
the fans if you've been watching the
show for a long time there'll be a lot
of deep cuts they might bring graviton
bats and then obviously there's the
Ghost Rider stuff left over because he
got sucked into the Dark Dimension he's
going to have to find his way back
eventually and it'll have something to
do with wrapping up the Darkhold plot
because that's the common denominator
that binds all of these story arcs the
dark hold itself it's the big MacGuffin
of the season so the real big thing here
is that people are wondering does that
mean if in humans the TV show is coming
is it going to replace agents of shield
in the schedule because it's not a
spin-off it's way more expensive and it
seems like it's going to be way more
popular at least at the outset because
this is big action set piece it's going
to be shot like a movie on IMAX cameras
that are even screening the first two
episodes in IMAX that's how big it's
going to be so the president of ABC was
talking about this he's like I feel like
shield can coexist with Inhumans so it's
not better intention to replace shield
but because ratings are declining what
they might end up doing like worst case
scenario because they haven't hit a
hundred episodes yet and that's a big
benchmark for TV is that they'll at
least give them a partial season five
renewal and they'll do like twelve or
thirteen episodes and then that will be
the final season of shield don't worry
about it too much now it's not that big
a deal we're getting ready to ramp up
for Iron Fist and all the Marvel movies
that are coming this year so schedule
change because I'm probably not going to
do more Legion videos till after the
series is done like I'll wait till after
episode 80 airs to do more Legion I'm
going to make Thursday's in Avengers day
so there will be a couple other days of
the week that I've bookmarked for
special videos I'll let you guys know
when I update the schedule there is a
new round of the Doctor Strange DVD
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video congratulations to last week's
giveaway winner shoe loud please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details what's
going to happen next is I'll post my
combined arrow legends of tomorrow video
and then I have some brand new really
cool Thor Ragnarok stuff to post while
you wait for that you can click here to
rewatch that Doctor Strange post-credit
scene and you can click here for all
about that mystery Namor project thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video